i did not
try to intimidate miss heard if she was
intimidated
why was she filming if she was scared to
death why didn't she leave
mr depp this
this is a text message exchange that you
had with paul bettany
on june 11 2013 correct yes
correct
in this text
mr depp
you text mr bettany let's burn amber
three exclamation points right you see
that introduce you then
and exhibit 325.
please
positive it but you you would agree that
um that you headbutt and misheard that
evening correct
no i would
vehemently disagree with that sir
i was trying to restrain mrs her
misheard
and
in the
once i had
restrained her um it's i i would say if
she's trying to still
move around and kick at me or trying to
get loose
any sort of movement when you're like
this and your heads are together this
close together
it's not impossible for for
for them to bump
did you give the following testimony in
response to the following questions
[Music]
have you drunk this whole thing this
morning oh you got this guy
you got this going
oh really
really
[Music]
and you would agree
that
you were violent in that clip correct
um
clearly i was having a bad
time
i don't uh i don't know what it was with
regard to completely at this point since
i don't know the date but um
um
being legally recorded by
your
um
chosen other is
uh
well it's quite fitting with the rest of
the photographs and
tape recordings she made so um
i thought what was most interesting is
that she
tried to hide it from me and then that
she
laughed
and smiled at the end
i thought that was the most interesting
part myself but so yes
i did assault
um a couple of cabins but i did not
touch miss hurt
as you can see i think no
and you may have been
you may have been
may have been drunk in that video
correct
there's a possibility of that yes sir
if you look at the bigger picture
when you're doing movies i've become
jealous and
crazy and weird and
you know we fight
a lot more
you